in a new interview this morning
President Trump says any attempt to
impeach him will have consequences well
you know I guess it says something like
high crimes and all I don't I don't know
how you can impeach somebody who's done
a great job I'll tell you what if I ever
got impeached I think the market would
crash we'll talk more about the
impeachment debate shortly in that Fox
News interview the president also says
he didn't know about Michael Cohen Ping
stormy Daniels and Karen McDougal until
later on and that the money was his the
president also tweeted after 1:00 a.m.
Eastern no collusion rigged witch-hunt
major Garen's at the White House major
good morning good morning reaction from
congressional Republicans has been
wobbly say good morning to the National
Park Service and we are told the major
party donors are alarmed in the face of
that President Trump has tried to calm
the turbulent legal waters about the
store the hush money payments made in
the heat of the 2016 campaign but legal
experts tell us the president's
assertion that he's in the clear because
though funds for those payments came for
him personally
well that doesn't quite get him off the
hook they weren't taken out of campaign
finance President Trump repeatedly said
secret payments from former attorney
Michael Cohen to two women who alleged
affairs with mr. Trump do not violate
federal campaign laws because they came
from mr. Trump's personal funds they
didn't come out of the campaign they
came from me and I tweeted about it
Cohen who has turned against the
president told a federal court he paid
Daniels quote in coordination with and
at the direction of then candidate Trump
to influence the election thereby
confessing to a violation of election
law they didn't come out of the campaign
and that's big
the president's claim also contradicts
this denial in April when he said he
knew nothing about Cohen's payment to
adult film star stormy Daniels
back in May mr. Trump acknowledged that
Cohen was reimbursed through a monthly
retainer to stop what he called false
and extortionist accusations about a
more than decade old affair now the
president claims he knew only after the
fact did you know about the payments
later on I knew later on which also
contradicts what was captured in a
secret recording by Cohen when he
discussed with mr. Trump one of the
payments to former Playboy model Karen
McDougal before the payment was made yes
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders said the president was not
worried he knows that he did nothing
wrong and that there was no collusion
sources tell us Republican party donors
are divided over the president's legal
woes small money donors part of the
fiercely loyal Trump base remained
precisely that fiercely loyal and
continued to pump money into party
coffers but big-money donors we are told
are both angry and confused by recent
developments all Republicans agree the
party will need every dollar it can find
to deal with an ever more difficult
political climate for the midterm
elections bianna major thank you no it
is fascinating to hear the president
even talking about the possibility of
impeachment I mean yeah I think a moment
just to pause that and take that in yeah
being raised that question about whether
he could be impeached in the consequence
of how far we've come and it's in play
now because he's named in the Cohen plea
documents and that is the only remedy
for a president if you believe that
president can't be indicted which the
Justice Department says is the case
exactly